[Musique]
savoir que ça je peux le dire la fin de
l'émission c'est peu c'est burlesque et
tout ce que tu voudras mais on a prévu à
peu près 300 tartes à la crème il ya des
bagarres générales avec tartas claire
entre le public et les artistes
je tends à mes deux réunis voilà donc si
tu veux venir mais je remercie les
bienvenus mambé tarte à la crème
voilà m et vous aurez une place sur le
prochain pour match de leur vie mais je
vais trouver quelque chose en accord
il va trouver t'inquiète pas patrick
pasqua bonjour lui qu'on est avec
patrick on détecte toute l'équipe et
tout le monde attend cette séquence tous
les bons mercredi qu'est-ce qui se passe
eh bien il ya des questions à la rue et
j'essaie d'y répondre
ban est aussi on adore c'est parti on y
va bonjour je m'appelle antonia je suis
une fidèle téléspectatrice de et pmp et
je pense que vous nous devez la vérité
y at il oui ou non des emplois fictifs
dans votre émission sur la codah je
comprends cette interrogation antonia et
c'est vrai qu'en écoutant parfois
certaines de nos interventions
on peut se poser la question mais non
tout et tout le monde travaille à tpm p
l'image de notre gourou cyril qui
réussit à rester concentré sur ces
chiffres pendant la pub même dans une
ambiance de boîte de nuit c'est très
impressionnant et d'ailleurs
exceptionnellement je voudrais lui
rendre hommage ce soir au nom de tous
les chroniqueurs de tpm p
pas dans la merde on verra le pizzadoor
homéopathie c'est mon kiff le pipeau
très bon gels et liquides au régal
chaque jour en inventant des nouveaux
jeux sous le regard bienveillant et
admiratif de matthieu delormeau à
l'instant un nouveau jeu à la con
cerveau récents sont télévision et
muscles ou là deux équipes
ra qui seront proposés aux questions et
d'autres aux muscles qu'est ce qui se
passe quand on est les deux vaincus moi
j'adore j'adore mais j'adore puisqu'il a
à voir plus si le jugement sur les
choses qui me paye le monde que tu vois
c'est moi qui avais la question est
intéressante celle de mathieu qu'est ce
qu'on fait quand on a le physique et
l'intelligence on n'était pas bien on
sait pas quoi faire
mais heureusement d'expier d'attirer au
sens quelqu'un dans le public on s'est
rendu compte que mathieu avait surtout
le physique voilà le 17 violé ses
partisans 17 violet pour jouer avec nous
le 17e violet marcy m'étais pas bien
aimé ce que tu mercier il est 17 il
étonné
[Applaudissements]
moi je me l'appliqué
à la pause avec un numéro
avoir la chance d'être habillé de la
bonne flèche battue c'est avant tout un
physique
ouais et d'ailleurs il a mis tout le
monde d'accord quand il s'est lancé dans
le développé couché là franchement y'a
pas de vanne juste un peu de respect
non ce cabot fait trois pour base une
petite je m'en fous
quelle bande de batam attend c'est trois
gros l'a pas capable de faire une
tu vois des savanes et il a été bon il a
levé 100 kg soit cette fois que quelque
chose l'a nommé 24 heures mais bon si
mathieu veut se consoler il peut
toujours compter sur le public
car oui il faut le reconnaître quand on
demande aux gens qu'ils aient leurs
chroniqueurs préférés il se passe
souvent ça a c'est vrai tu as confiance
mais je croyais avait préféré ici sur
l'équipe s'est évidemment pas mathieu
c'est monsieur en bresse et matures
devraient y avait 1 sur 1
attention d'ailleurs qu'il va devoir
lever et toi aussi
[Musique]
mamma mia le projet demandera
et toi aussi des ann mathieu a
je me suis grillé seul parce que j'étais
vraiment son chroniqueur préféré
vraiment sur son frère comme d'habitude
allez c'est minable
car il n'y a pas d'emplois fictifs dans
l'émission mais il ya quand même
quelques magouilles bail que je me dois
de révéler ce soir va commencer par une
très sombre affaire c'est quoi les
quelques semaines j'avais montrer les
méfaits de jean michel qui très cher au
jeu avec les deux complices de tirs est
mort auditifs ventriloque
j'ai malheureusement il a récidivé
non
[Musique]
alors qu'est-ce que je situe le contexte
ce sont là cyril hanouna que mokhtar
appel en privé la pépite du paf a laissé
les commandes de tpm ps julien combes et
la sptr télévision et fenêtres
d'habitude l'émission commence par un
jeu à la dotation généreuse un voyage à
madrid l'obtenir les chroniqueurs
doivent remplir au maximum des valises
avec des vêtements la plus lourde on
verra son propriétaire au pays des
castagnettes et du chorizo perdant sur
un déguise en poussins quoi de plus
normal pour une émission médias mais
l'échec est impensable pour celui qu'on
appelle le cerveau des vosges
discrètement pour rendre sa valise plus
lourde il dépose la bouteille d'eau que
la production lui a généreusement donné
à la pause publicitaire puis par aux
toilettes
pourquoi faire secouer le colosse comme
il aime à le dire
c'est jean-michel et partis s'isoler
c'est qu'il avait une idée en tête des
images accablantes de sa conversation en
caroline l'assistante de prod
m
hello
palou d'edo patois
mais chut
[Musique]
m
vainqueur sans heurts
on
vous avez l'argent
[Musique]
les bateaux les gens
[Applaudissements]
aussi battre excusé le 5 juin au final
il a perdu la finale que costume de
poussins et ça s'est pas arrêté là non
quant à faire un génie à la pause
publicitaire suivante jean michel va se
souvenir que pour faire pencher la
balance en sa faveur
il est pas mis que de l'eau et du savon
liquide dans la valise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'écoute email
[Musique]
elle adore bon d'accord on adore ça
génial vous savez pourquoi tout ça s'est
passé quoi parce que ce genre la syrie
n'était pas là non ils étaient en
séminaire avec les grands patrons du
groupe canal+
j'ai d'ailleurs les images exclusives de
son intervention la tribune pour
présenter ses idées pour 2017
[Musique]
dans le cas de tous car il en al astal à
une autre sombre affaire et d'autres
sont bien qui concerne franck gastambide
à allauch à une autre sombre affaire
dans un instant alors je vais revenir
sur une autre affaire sont de tpm paix
c'était la venue de franck gastambide le
plateau notre poste surtout sa rencontre
avec un de ses amis d'enfance à pour
ceux qui auraient manqué ce moment très
émouvant qui nous attirer quelques armes
qui rappelle c'est drôle c'est à cette
période que tu rencontres une personne
qui va beaucoup compter pour toi franck
si je te dis ludovic est ce que ça
t'évoque quelque chose c'est possible
regarde
ludovic
[Musique]
avec maintenant que j'avais pas vu non
je te suis face à ça non je ne suis pas
c
alors c'est pas du loup alors comment
est ce possible commenceront que n'at-il
pas pu reconnaître ses meilleurs amis
est ce que le succès du raid monter la
tête eh bien pas du tout car s'il ya
bien un mec simple c'est franck par
contre voilà ce qui s'est passé juste
avant ces images aussi accablantes
c'est le manque de nouvelles maps et
pentue comment par ludovic l'école
comme il ya en fait la limite qui va se
passer son complet des photos d'enfance
montré des photos d'enfance et d'honneur
ou est ce que vous connaissez cette
personne n'a envie sûr que non
je voudrais dire aux téléspectateurs
c'est vrai qu'on voulait piégé franck
gastambide est vraiment et il n'a pas
voulu du tout en fait ce que tout était
prêt vous voulez dû faire comme avec
julien lepers une fausse meuf info gars
est en fait il est inapte à il a pas il
n'a pas voulu
au fait tu vois là mais qu'est-ce qu'il
était drôle et c'est encore plus drôle
qui disent non je ne rentrent pas dans
notre île je pense que si tu es et donc
voilà on en bref conte gaston minutes en
temps réel et courir est ce que moi je
le chauffer à mort mais le plus drôle
c'est la suite quoi ah oui je vous
resituer franck à ce moment là est en
dépression vous coup monté de cyril est
en plein cauchemar
si c'est là que mathieu va intervenir ça
se savait pas il n'aurait pas dû parce
que ça va vous donnez pas le vendre la
semaine mais mais le vent du siècle car
au niveau d une jolie 3 après quoi ces
petits coups d'une poule et 3 passes
là
[Applaudissements]
barack obama il regarde c'est parti
quelques modifs holding les trois vrai
quoi
[Applaudissements]
la foire c'est même ce qui nous
embrassons pro qui vous regardent codem
fort et formidable franck regarder ce
qu'il ya la suite parce que franck sera
aussi le cauchemar a continué à lors des
dernières captures tient expliqué à abc
là que son nom commençait à bien circulé
dans le cinéma engagé d un accord soit
le réalisateur du prochain taxi mais
moment embarrassant de la semaine 10
passes pour conduire à taxer on nous
annonce un mec un peu voler son
compatriote 0
non mais alors
en clair est marla est au bout du
rouleau mais malheureusement pour lui
c'est pas fini
[Musique]
on cherche la dernière
en cherchant pas longtemps toi moi je
tourne en masse
montez à bord il
- pas tout est vrai c'est qu'il est il a
hésité un moment c'est pas dit c'est
maintenant que j'en tire aux clients
d'accepter ou pas et va nous répondre il
faut de vrais championnats maximum de
clients ont coûté aux voilà il en train
de regarder au kimono
il a gardé malick pour garder le col de
taxi pour pourquoi pas c'est de faire
ses choix mais s'ils sont mauvais mais
en revanche pour jouer un client ou pas
enfin accueillons pas à la ligue va être
excellent mois et on peut d'abord il est
peut être bon avec lui personne voulant
s'assurer coûté bio plus tôt en tout cas
cela fait une magnifique transition pour
évoquer tout ce qu'on n'aurait pas j'ai
la réponse de franck avec skis dit
regardez vous avez à dire vous même
jamais de la vie
gaston jamais de la vie même pas smiley
derrière aller simple et tellement de
peine
pas facile alors laissé la transition
pour arriver à tout ce qu'on avait pu
voir et entendre cette semaine et on
commence par la rebelle de la semaine
isabelle morini-bosc elle quand elle
n'aime pas elle aime pas de fait savoir
et aussi par mathieu qui se
réjouissaient de la disparition de la
rubrique de tirs est mort au lait cru
hier comme ça
en attendant
et vraiment les deux connaissent glisse
vous savez que derrière le poste va
s'arrêter oui ils vont faire vous devez
faire deux sous le poste allez merci
c'est bon allez ainsi benjamin castaldi
coup pas peu dire quand même des
sympathies
lobo aussi comment ça peut être ta meuf
au cn océane et les eaux j'ai deux
semaines pour faire 5 kg et beaucoup
semaine pile et moules
la ville est prête à faire un bisou à ma
que malgré ce tir aient sur la bouche ou
sur la joue dans la bouche sur le q quel
est ton style de mec tu peux dire un
grand blond avec une chaussure noire
matthieu delormeau n'oserait plus tôt
[Applaudissements]
mais le gardien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
thématique très charmante et très
sympathique et qui a joué le jeu je peux
vous dire qu'elle a passé un sale moment
avec vous je vous le dis bah oui on
connaît votre haleine non c'est fini
merci
[Applaudissements]